all right welcome back everybody today
is the last in our lecture series on the
fast fourier transform and this is
actually one of my favorite ones so this
is some really really cool theory about
FFT and image compression okay FFT and
image compression okay so we'll do a
really neat matlab demo for the second
half of the class but to start with I
really just want to kind of give you an
idea of why it's possible in the first
place to compress images so let's think
about that most of the images we deal
with on a day to day basis are in fact
heavily compressed so if you take a
picture with your cell phone the picture
that's stored is highly compressed when
you watch television or listen to music
all of those signals have been
compressed before you consume them so
I'm going to start off with a really
simple maybe even kind of deceptively
simple example so we're going to
consider a very simple image we're going
to consider an image that is 10 by 10
pixels okay this is a very small image
where each pixel can either be black or
white okay so where each pixel can be
either black or white
alright so this is a nice simplification
because it can just be binary right I
can say that it's either 0 or 1 and each
of the ten pixels can be 0 or 1 ok
simple right I mean a 10 pixel image is
really really coarse so the first
question is how many possible images are
there
okay how many possible ten-by-ten images
with pixel being either black or white
are there while I write this up just be
thinking about that's how many how many
possible images are there
so when I give this lecture alive
oftentimes I get the answer a hundred
possible images but that's not correct
just because there are a hundred pixels
does not mean that there are a hundred
possible images right let's see let's
just draw up a crude example this isn't
exactly ten but you get the picture
right I have a I can either choose a 0
or 1 in the first pixel and
independently I can choose a 0 or a 1 in
the second pixel and a third and the
fourth and so on and so forth so the
answer is that there are actually 2 to
the 100 possible images now 2 to the 100
is a very large number this is
approximately 10 to the power 30
okay now we're used to hearing about big
numbers now right the national debt is
some tens of trillions of dollars right
my hard drive has hundreds of gigabytes
but this is an even larger number okay
we're talking about very very very crude
simple images here very simple 10 by 10
images and there are 10 to the power 30
possible black-and-white images now 10
to the 30 is more than the conservative
estimate for grains of sand on planet
Earth this is the number of stars in the
observable universe think about that
there are more 10 by 10 black-and-white
images possible then there are stars in
the known universe that's amazing
how can that possibly be this seems
absurd how can this be
okay well the answer the answer is
actually quite simple
the vast majority the absolute vast
majority of images so answer the vast
majority of images are just completely
random noise so the vast majority of
images are kind of noise and when I say
noise I literally mean like television
static so you're watching this lecture
on some kind of a flat digital screen
probably but before flat digital screens
right
we had CRT televisions and if you had it
turned on to a no channel like some
channel you didn't have you would get
this static noise okay that's what the
vast majority of these images look like
so let's let's imagine that I'm just
throwing darts in the space of all
possible images all of the images that
pop up are going to be just completely
random just noise right put a random
number here here here here here here
fill this with random zeros or ones and
it's just gonna look like TV static okay
so this vast space of possible images is
mostly filled with TV static but very
rarely there are images that actually
make sense right like I can have I don't
know if I can draw this but it's
probably possible to make smiley faces
okay so in the space of mostly
meaningless noise images the images we
care about occupy a tiny tiny minuscule
fraction of image space okay so I'm
gonna write that on another board this
is kind of a cool concept
so therefore
natural images and natural images is
some jargon that we use to describe all
things you'd ever care about seeing
things that mean something to people
mean mean natural so ie
people's faces mountains I mean if you
look at a picture of this lecture hall
that's a natural image what you're
looking at right now is a natural image
okay it doesn't have to be natural like
outdoorsy it can be a bridge that
somebody built that's a natural image it
means something special to us it's not
just white noise random so therefore
natural images occupy a tiny tiny
fraction of image space okay and in some
sense this is the entire basis of image
compression which is pretty cool so this
is the basis of image compression
now I'm gonna give you let's put an
exclamation mark these are all pretty
profound statements okay this is pretty
cool that even in simple crummy little
10 by 10 images that are only black and
white there's more possible images than
stars in the known universe and all the
pictures that you will ever see in your
entire life occupy the tiniest corner of
that image space in fact images that you
will never see in your entire life also
occupy a tiny corner of image space so
this is a weird kind of metaphysical
moment there is a vector there is an
image in image space of you being born
maybe no one was there to take a picture
but if you sifted through all of the
random images for long enough you would
see a picture okay
that's weird right okay so the process
is as follows it's a pretty
straightforward procedure for image
compression we take our image which is a
set of pixels and we take the FFT so we
get this is a two-dimensional FFT you
about that all in a minute but let's
just say I can break it into FFT and so
what I get is my image this is the exact
full you know all the information image
and I get this in frequencies okay now
it turns out that when I do this
most of these frequencies tend to be
small this is um this is just another
way of saying that natural images occupy
a tiny fraction of image space when we
transform our pixels to frequencies most
of those frequencies are really small so
then we truncate small values small
frequencies and that gives me my
compressed image
but I'm still in frequency space so this
is still in frequency components and so
then I finally have to take the inverse
Fourier transform okay so I take my eye
FFT
to get my compressed image in pixels
okay and this is exactly what JPEG
compression does so when you have
there's actually something called JPEG
2000 which is like better than JPEG but
this is the basic vanilla JPEG encoding
algorithm I take an image with my camera
it's got a boatload of pixels way too
much information so I take the FFT most
of the values of the frequencies are
small so I throw most of them away and
then the compressed image that you save
on your hard drive you're just saving
the few frequencies that are large and
when you want to view them on your TV or
on your computer screen it quickly does
an inverse Fourier transform to
reconstruct the pixels okay pretty cool
it's a not too complicated actually okay
so that's the basic idea maybe I'll tell
you I told you that this is a
two-dimensional a FFT so remember that
our FFT takes some signal like for
example if I had an audio signal in time
you know volume per time then the FFT
would give me a bunch of frequencies
kind of this would be the sum of a bunch
of sine waves in time well the same
thing can be done with a two-dimensional
image so if I have a two-dimensional
image what I can do is I can add up sine
waves in let's call this X&Y I can have
sine waves in X and sine waves in Y and
I add those combinations up to
reconstruct the values at the pixels
okay so mathematically it's no more
complicated algorithmically it's a
little more complicated but fortunately
MATLAB has built-in fft to command which
gives me the two dimensional FFT okay so
this takes a little bit of getting used
to wrapping your head around this just
just imagine think of how many possible
megapixel images exist when they're not
limited to black and white so we were
talking about these little black and
white 10 by 10 you know black and white
pixel images imagine now you take a
megapixel image on your fancy camera and
it can have hundreds of possible color
values between you know white to black
and all the grays in between and red
green and blue so the number of possible
images is it's one of the largest
numbers that humans had ever conceived
of actually it's like if all of the
atoms in the universe shook hands with
all of the other atoms in the universe
okay it's it's a it's a really
frequently large number okay so now
we're gonna dive into some really cool
MATLAB examples and we're actually going
to write our own image compression
software we are going to write software
to do JPEG compression okay so let's
dive into some MATLAB code on the
computer and I'll just wait until we get
synced up here so that you can see
what's on my screen
so while I'm waiting I'm going to type
in my computer clear all closed all CLC
good so now you can see my computer so
that clears everything okay so this is
pretty cool what I'm gonna show you is
the following I have a folder on my hard
drive hopefully I can find it so I have
a folder on my hard drive called FFT
image and I have some cool images on
here right I have rosie the riveter
and I have this funny this is kind of a
funny one math on tape is hard to follow
so please listen carefully okay and I
have some other great images on here
like a hippie
Einstein dog and a cat kissing this all
good stuff the famous National
Geographic photo of the girl from
Afghanistan so what we're going to do is
we're going to just kind of play around
with some of these images and see if we
can write our own software to compress
them and this is actually very very
similar to what we used to filter our
audio signal we're going to take our
image we're gonna transform it to
Fourier coefficients and we're
essentially going to filter out the
noise and in doing so we will have
compressed the image okay so the first
step let me just make sure I have a good
sense of time so the first step here is
I'm going to load a full image so I want
to print out to the screen that I'm
loading an image okay and I'm going to
say a equals image read recorder and I
think recorder is a dot JPEG so this is
a excuse me a built-in MATLAB command
image read and I'm telling it that I
want to read
this file recorder and that it's a type
jpg okay
I'm gonna create a figure and I'm going
to show this image so that's all for now
f5
oh man ok so this is the image that
we're gonna work with maybe I'll
actually choose a slightly better image
I'll do the hippie excuse me and I have
to put a semicolon after this or else it
spits out all of the values of that that
matrix ok so just to see this is our
hippie okay okay so nothing against
hippies my parents were hippies okay so
let's see what the size of this thing is
the size of a okay so a is a matrix I
load in this image and the image is a
matrix okay it's got a eleven hundred
and one by 750 that's the dimensions of
the image and then it has three channels
for red green and blue color okay now to
simplify this example I'm going to just
consider a gray channel where I kind of
average out all the color so I'm going
to going to now make my image black and
whites or really gray so my a a is what
I'm calling my image so a BW is my red
green blue to gray of a this is a built
in MATLAB command okay and then I'm
going to say NX by and Y is equal to the
size of this thing
and I'm going to make a figure
and I'm going to show my image okay and
I'm going to compress this image so I'm
going to label this one the original
image in a large font that you can read
it okay cool
so I took my original picture of the
color hippie and now I've gone all the
way down to red green
sorry I've removed all of the color
channels and now we're just dealing with
a grayscale image okay excuse me
so now this is the interesting step
where we compress our image okay so the
well actually this before we compress
we're just going to compute the fft of
our image using FFT - so I'm gonna say
doing FFT analysis for sparsity check
tell you what that means in a minute
so the disp command just prints it to
the screen so that I know what's
happening because these might actually
take some time so I want to kind of have
my computer tell me what its cranking on
okay and I'm actually going to time the
calculation I'm gonna say tick so it's
gonna start my timer and then I'm going
to say a transformed equals fftw
sorry FFT - of ABW my black and white
image cool and then f equals the log of
the absolute value of the FFT shift of a
transformed plus one okay so I'm just
making it so I can plot this thing in a
way that we can all see it and I'm just
kind of fiddling with this Fourier
coefficients F equals matrix - gray so
it's going to take my matrix of values
and turn it into a grayscale image and
then I'm gonna make a figure
and this is displaying the fft
coefficients okay
okay so if I run this I get my hippie
and then this is the two dimensional FFT
of my grayscale image this is the two
dimensional FFT of the grayscale image
okay now it's a little hard to see this
is a high resolution it has the exact
same resolution as my image right
because when I take the F of T of data I
get something that's exactly the same
size but if i zoom in here you'll see
that you know a lot of these are black
or kind of low gray colors but really
there's some in the middle that are
bright white and those are the high
Fourier coefficient values okay so I am
telling you that this thing is mostly
sparse right it's most of the elements
are small and can be neglected but some
of the bigger Fourier coefficients are
really important okay so what we're
going to now do but excuse me let's see
yeah so what we're going to do now the
final thing we're going to do is we're
going to find all of the small
coefficients in our FFT and zero them
out just like we did before for the
audio data okay
so now we're gonna zero out all small
coefficients and inverse transform okay
so I'm printing to the screen that I'm
zeroing out small Fourier coefficients
okay and now I'm gonna tick again I
guess I never talked so let's see
forget it I'm not going to count the
time okay
okay so this count pick is just a
counter I'm using to step through my
subplots so don't pay attention to that
okay so for a threshold equals 0.1 times
0.05 0.01 times the maximum of the
maximum of the absolute value of my
transformed FFT okay let me tell you
what's happening here so basically I
have my FFT and some values are big and
some values are small and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to set a threshold so
that any values below my threshold I'm
setting them equal to zero I don't care
if they're not exactly zero I'm going to
set them equal to zero and that way I
don't have to store as many numbers okay
so I'm setting up this threshold which
is some number times the biggest FFT
value and anything below the threshold
I'm going to throw away and we have a
nice way of doing that we say the
indices I want to keep are when my
absolute value of my transformed a are
greater than threshold okay so now
indices IND is a matrix the same size as
my image and is my FFT and now what I do
is I say my low-pass filtered a is equal
to a transform times my indices and I do
dot times so it does it element by
element right so I had my FFT and my
indices and I go for each you know
frequency if it if its coefficients
larger than the threshold it multiplies
by one and I keep it if it's below
threshold I multiply it by zero and I
lose it
and
and then I'm going to count how many
nonzero indices there are I just want to
know how much information am i throwing
away and how much am i keeping okay so
the percentage that I'm keeping is 100 -
count / NX x NY times 100 okay and then
the final thing I have to do is inverse
Fourier transform this kind of low pass
filtered matrix of fft coefficients so a
lo equals u int 8 I'm making it an
integer of IFFT to of a too low
so I take the inverse Fourier transform
of my low pass filter transformed a then
I make it so that those numbers are this
you int 8 datatype that's just so I can
plot it as an image okay so I'm going to
go back to my figure 1 and I'm going to
subplot 2 comma 2 comma the current one
I'm on count pick and I'm gonna do an
image show of my low-pass filtered a
okay
I'm going to draw it now and I'm gonna
say the title of this thing is the
percentage percentage of FFT basis okay
so I want to keep track of how much am i
how much of the Fourier coefficients am
I actually keeping and okay so I'm going
to run this thing now we load the full
image and here's what we get okay so the
procedure is as follows I take my full
image here my greyscale image IFFT to
get my Fourier coefficients most of them
are really small so I create a threshold
and I throw away all of the coefficients
that are below that threshold and here
are the examples of what it looks like
when I do that so if I keep 27 you know
26.5% of my coefficients I get an image
that's pretty much indistinguishable if
I keep 5% I still get a great image I
can see his peace sign and you know all
kinds of details and even when I only
keep 1.3 percent of the image I still
get kind of a very good representation
of the original image if i zoom in here
you can start seeing that's a little bit
grainy right so you can start seeing the
image degradation in the the highly
compressed case but it's still
remarkably good okay so I want to try
this on another couple of examples just
so that we get a feeling for what's
really going on here because this can
kind of seem like magic until you really
get a nice feeling for what's going on
okay so that was the hippie let's try
another one
I like the National Geographic one
because it's really high resolution and
has a lot of neat features
okay so this is the original image it's
very high-resolution very striking high
color image if you zoom in I mean you
can actually see like the iris part of
her eye so this is really a phenomenal
high-resolution image and when we run
through our code we see in the upper
left this is our uncompressed full image
the FFT of that image looks like this so
there's this region in the middle where
the values are much larger
you know much larger and as we go out
they become smaller and smaller and less
and less important and in this case I
can get away with throwing away a lot of
my Fourier coefficients so even when I
only keep a you know a third of a
percent of my FFT coefficients I can
clearly tell you know without a doubt
what image this is even though I lose
some details so I'm just gonna zoom in
to the eye so we can see how good each
of these compressions is really doing
okay so when I keep 8 percent of the FFT
basis we can see the eye and a little
scar and the hair when we're throwing
away you know 99 more than 99% of the
data you can still see that there's an
eye but you lose the fine resolution
features ok so this is the basic kind of
idea of image compression now there's a
few interesting points that should be
made let's see so one interesting point
is that the larger my starting image
this is not always true but this is
generally true like for example if I'm
taking the same object this this girl's
face and I'm going to take I could take
a low resolution picture of it or an
a high-resolution picture of the same
image then the high-resolution image is
going to be more compressible I'm going
to be able to throw away more of my
Fourier coefficients the higher kind of
the larger the original starting picture
and that really speaks to this idea that
the image space is so phenomenally large
right if I have a 10 by 10 image yeah
it's a big image space but it's not even
nearly as big as a thousand by a
thousand image ok so natural images are
even more sparse sparse meaning they can
be represented with only a few
coefficients they are more sparse when
they're in a higher dimensional image
space ok which is why this image is
higher resolution than the hippie which
is why I can throw away more of the
coefficients and still get pretty good
resolution ok and just to reiterate the
procedure I take the natural image I
take the Fourier transform the
two-dimensional FFT to I threshold and
throw away most of the non 0 the
approximately zero elements and I only
have to keep track of a tiny fraction of
the coefficients cool let's go back to
another example that is pretty neat
let's try this dog cat image so that is
the point I want to make
okay so this is an adorable picture of a
dog nosing cats okay and I'm going to
flatten it to gray compute the FFT zero
out all the small coefficients and
inverse transform now this is
interesting
here it actually takes a large amount of
coefficients to get pretty clean signal
reproduction and even by the time I go
down to eight percent of modes that I'm
keeping let's just zoom in here are
little bits I've already started to
degrade significantly and one of the
things that's really interesting about
how this image degrades is that for
example I start to really lose the
texture of the grass and the hair and
the fur of these animals and so this is
a second point that I want to make just
kind of an interesting side note is that
complicated textures are actually among
the most difficult features and images
to compress because they really this
grass looks a lot like TV static right
there's a lot of details and textures
and statistics that you have to get
right to get that image correct and so
the Fourier transform is not as sparse
you can't exactly see it here but it's
not so hair and fur and grass are
particularly challenging things to
compress in images interestingly enough
this was actually a major problem for
the Pixar animation studio which is one
of the main reasons that their first big
kind of computer graphics movie was Toy
Story because it's much much easier to
render plastic skin then you know the
fuzzy monsters and monsters ink
okay so this was actually a conscious
decision by this animation crew and they
had
to invest years of software development
before they could make realistic fuzzy
monsters okay
so this is kind of an interesting
outfall of some of these compression
techniques good okay I think I have a
couple more points to make but this is
close to it
big picture images are highly
compressible there's a beautiful new
theory it's incredibly profound it's
called compressive sensing and what
compressive sensing says is that what
people are doing nowadays with their
high-end cameras is that they take a
super high-resolution image then they
Fourier transform compress it right they
Fourier transform they throw away 99% of
the data and then they just keep that 1%
of special data ok this is what
everybody's been doing for you know
decades right we have take all this huge
image data with your sensor compress it
and then store it the truly phenomenal
observation of an annual can Dez and
Terence Tao two of the greatest
mathematicians alive today they realized
about 10 years ago that if my image is
highly compressible if I only need 1% of
the Fourier coefficients then all I
actually need to do is find some way of
randomly sampling maybe 3 or 5 percent
of my pixels like I literally take my
image and I only collect 3 percent of
the pixels I don't collect a megapixel I
just only pull in 3 percent of the data
and because that image is sparse in
Fourier domain in the Fourier basis
meaning that most of the Fourier
frequencies are approximately 0 I can
almost certainly reconstruct what the
image should be to satisfy that sparsity
principle ok
I'm not going to go more into depth in
this it's kind of a it's a little bit of
a mind-bending phenomenon that's called
compressive sensing you can read all
about it
compressive sensing the big names are
Donahoe Candace Tao and Brainiac
although there's others Gilbert's and
Trop are notable others this theory has
the potential to change everything they
can probably change the way that we do
physics and image capture and data
analysis as much as the FFT changed the
way that we do telecommunications okay
so really the possibilities with
compressive sensing are almost limitless
it's gonna dramatically change how we
for example think about all high
dimensional systems so when I think
about the climate of the earth the earth
weather systems
I need billions of pieces of information
to represent that state in a way to
simulate it but we know that there are
these low order kind of large coherent
features to whether there's hurricanes
and you know thick boundary layers and
there's all kinds of large-scale geo
scale phenomenon which means that in
some basis all of this weather data is
sparse and we might be able to represent
it with a much fewer number of sensors
and data okay so that's all I'm gonna
say about that let's just go back to the
MATLAB for a moment let's see if I can
bring back this one
just gonna run all of my code one more
time okay so I said that us an FFT to
write a two-dimensional FFT is pretty
easy to think about so the way I think
about this I'm gonna wave my arms a
little bit the way I think about a
two-dimensional FFT is as follows
imagine that I have my image so my image
is a bunch of numbers right there big
numbers the lighter regions there are
small numbers for the darker regions and
I have this two-dimensional image that
has some landscape based on the kind of
color and brightness at each pixel so
what I think about is imagine I have a
bedsheet that's held taut at four ends
and I have four people holding this
bedsheet taut and i shart I start
shaking it at a particular frequency so
I'm gonna get a standing wave on that
bedsheet and let's say that the guys on
either side of me are also forcing at a
different frequency
that's one Fourier coefficient of this
two dimensional Fourier transform okay
so I have one standing wave in the X
direction there's another standing wave
in the Y direction that's just one
coordinate and I add up all of those
different frequencies standing waves and
I get this complex topography of my
image that sounds crazy it sounds like
I'm just making stuff up but you can
actually see this which is kind of cool
I was explaining this to my mom actually
and I realized that I could just make a
picture in MATLAB so I'm gonna image
resize my black-and-white image I'm down
sampling it a little bit and I'm gonna
create a surface let's see let's see
what we get
there's my image okay so this is the
surface I'm talking about this is the
bedsheet that's been held taut and
everyone's forcing it and there are
different Fourier directions and now
let's say I look at this
this is gonna blow your mind notice whoa
there you go that's what the image
really looks like this is the data
representation of that image right some
regions are higher than others if
they're lighter or darker now we're
bluer or whatever I mean this is you
know you there's lots of ways of
representing this and I can construct
this by essentially thinking about well
what are the different kind of frequency
standing waves of this two-dimensional
top bedsheet that add up to give me this
shape here and if I recall this is
actually the unfiltered image let me see
if that's the unfiltered image a new
yeah so let's make another figure and
say a new low equals M resize a low
point one surf double a new low
let's just see what our low-pass
filtered image looks like
okay so the image on the left is the raw
data uncompressed and the image on the
right is the compressed version of the
data this is the heavily compressed
version actually so I'm just going to
get them so that they're kind of in the
same orientation okay and what we notice
here I think maybe it's a little hard to
tell is that the compressed image is
just kind of rounding out some of these
jagged peaks okay so there's a lot of
kind of jaggedy noisy peaks in here and
when I filter using the Fourier
transform when I compress and throw away
some of those frequencies
I'm just essentially getting a slightly
smoother version of this image but
basically all of the features are still
there
okay so I hope this has been an
interesting and kind of intriguing demo
of some of the uses of the fast Fourier
transform I'd like to point out that
absolutely none of this would be
possible if it wasn't for the fast
Fourier transform and there's this
entirely wonderful new set of techniques
called compressive sensing that are just
emerging kind of just hitting the
markets that are gonna change everything
okay so that's all for today
that's my lecture on the fast Fourier
transform so thank you